All right, so let's continue our discussion
of this.
Joe Biden, you praying the conspiracy
theory, which is unfortunately getting way
more attention than it deserves, given that
it is completely and easily debunked, particularly
when the real story here, it's a serious real
story, is that Donald Trump has made yet another
attempt to really a demand in this case to
collude with a foreign power.
This time it's Ukraine.
Trump is withholding hundreds of millions
of dollars in military aid if and until such
time as Ukraine smears Joe Biden in order
to help Trump win reelection in 2020.
So Rudy Giuliani, Donald Trump's lawyer went
on Fox news.
And usually when I tell you that there was
some kind of pushback on Fox news or some
counter narrative or some grain of truth,
it's Shepard Smith or Chris Wallace, or one
time Neil Cavuto this time it's actually a
Fox news reporter, John Robert.
So I think as formerly of CNN, or maybe it
was CBS or ABC, I don't remember in any case,
John Roberts interviewed Rudy Giuliani on
Fox, his Sunday program.
And to his credit, John Roberts not only did
a little devil's advocate stuff with Rudy
where he said, you know, this doesn't look
appropriate for you to go to Ukraine looking
for dirt on Biden and getting people to smear
him.
Uh, John Roberts actually holds firm and a
little bit presses Rudy Giuliani.
Let's take a look.
We're there to investigate alleged Ukrainian
interference in the 2016 election.
Defend.
All right, so when did this morph into an
investigation of Joe Biden and hundred Biden
and is it appropriate for you as a representative
of the president to be going to Ukraine and
finding dirt on Joe Biden and or his son to
use politically in 2020 that's the way you
characterize it.
It's certainly a pulled away.
That's the way it appears to line up.
No, it doesn't.
You went there for one thing that does something
else and that's what you've been doing for
as Biden media lines it up.
This began with someone coming to me saying,
this information can clear your client about
the corruption in Ukraine between the Ukraine,
the democratic party, the ambassador and the
FBI agent who investigated the date.
But then, but then it forced into Biden inextricably
combined because Biden had the guy fired Shoken.
By the way, his statements on record, the
lazy press could go read it, don't have to
listen to me.
There are three video, the prosecutors on
record available on here.
So the immediate reaction is that Fox news
should be embarrassed merely to have aired
this.
And Giuliani shouldn't even be allowed on
these shows anymore since all he does is lie.
But okay, that probably was not John Robert's
call.
Given the expectations and the setting, this
isn't bad, but you know that you've reached
new lows in terms of what you're doing and
the absurdity of what you're saying when you're
a Republican.
And during a Fox news interview, you're challenged.
And not just to get some symbolic amount of
disagreement on the record, but you get an
actual challenge, at least to the extent
that we would expect to see on Fox news.
In a sense, it's relieving, but it's also
horrifying because it's hard to imagine things
getting so bad as a normal state of affairs
for the presidential administration that even
Fox news feels obligated to push back against
the absolutely absurd, unbelievable claims
and actions of Rudy Giuliani.
Now there's a fear of criticism to be made
of John Roberts here.
Uh, and the criticism is asking whether it's
appropriate for Rudy to do this doesn't even
remotely get to the heart of the problem,
which is that this should be criminal if it
is not.
And if it's not, it's not criminal because
American law didn't even account for the possibility
of a president doing what Donald Trump and
Giuliani are doing for the benefit of Donald
Trump's reelection campaign in 2020 threatening
to do and then actually withholding military
aid to Ukraine if an until they smear Joe
Biden is so outside of what anyone imagined
a president might do.
That is Renato Mariotti told us in his political
piece over the weekend, it could actually
be difficult to get Trump on bribery or corruption
because this is so high level in terms of
the international nature of it, that American
law may not even actually cover what it is
that has taken place here.
The other thing that I've been thinking about
the last couple of days is, aside from whether
the Trump administration calculated that copping
to elements of what
is being alleged publicly may be better than
the full truth getting out, which we may never
know.
Consider how many countries have had similar
conversations with Donald Trump that we've
simply not found out about, right?
Who else is Donald Trump extorting internationally,
implicitly or explicitly that
we haven't heard about?
And I think the iceberg analogy works well
here with an iceberg.
90% of it or some large percentage is under
the waterline.
You only see the tip of the iceberg.
That's where the phrase comes from.
In this administration, I
can only, uh, be led to believe by the actions
of the administration that the same iceberg
analogy applies in the interim at the micro
level.
Okay?
It was good that
John
Roberts asked at least
a few pressing questions, uh, to Rudy Giuliani.